I sent you the Vegas odds yeah I was
just about that you know I always go to
Vegas here forget about Republican
opinions forget about Democratic
opinions Vegas knows so if you pull up
the Vegas odds I think I sent them to
you earlier Tyler
where are they right now
going up by just oh wow oh they're tied
they're neck and neck 300 300. they're
above Biden you got Kamala and here's
scary yeah Gavin do something right here
no chance I've given my opinion on this
I could be wrong shoot me down all day
if Trump goes against a Gavin Newsom
as much as I think that Gavin Newsom is
the fakest most plastic guy ever Newsom
will beat Trump I think I think any
Republican has a shot at the White House
Trump's last on the list so so
good commentary I'll I'll give you a
couple things from my thoughts that I
agree with you number one uh the way I I
just sold PHP right insurance company
the way I led the company the first six
months to 18 months that doesn't work in
the fifth year that doesn't work in the
10th year that doesn't work after you
sell the company
the same strategy doesn't work in a
different season this is a different
season for Trump so you know as a coach
the way your team won one way you're not
going to win the same way because your
best player was a center and now your
best player is a two guard now your best
player is a point guard now your best
players are number four you're not going
to win the same way it's the coach's
ability to adjust and play with the
current players you have I don't know if
he's going to be able to do it or not
we're gonna find that this is a very
different strategy the same strategy in
2020 2016 is not going to win today
correct what is going to work in 2016 he
has to look at what worked for 2016.
what worked in 2016 is he kept talking
same policies over and over and over and
over again that worked what didn't work
in 2020 is victim they're coming after
me they're coming after me they're
coming after me they're coming after me
that didn't work so you have to kind of
make that adjustment is he gonna use
that or not we have no idea the other
thing I will tell you as well on this
and then I want to go to the Iran topic
because we only got 19 minutes left
um here's the other part the the best
part about competition and sports okay
we said this a few weeks ago when Dylan
says the Eagles are going to win it the
Eagles just ended up losing to the
commanders I was in DC they were
celebrating because there's Eagles fans
there's commanders fans and uh
way way too early right now man we have
no idea what's going to be happening the
next 18 months no idea on what's going
to be upon 18 months do not get it
twisted I guarantee you the left is
sitting on some kind of a dirt on
DeSantis the day he wins the nominee for
the Republican the next week month three
months six months they're gonna come out
with stuff against the Santas they're
gonna wait to see who's gonna be in this
election or not they're going to watch
you see who's going to run on the
Republican side or not we're going to
see who are going to be the candidates
running right now if you look at some of
the list of names that you hear about
potentially running Christy may be
running uh uh uh Nikki Haley may be
running Pompeo may be running Tim Scott
may be running uh Hutchinson may be
running Hogan may be running Junkin
maybe running the Santas may be running
Pence may be running there's a lot of
people that may be running on the right
it is way too early right now to be
betting on what's going to be happening
but if you're like mattress back and
you're willing to bet on the ass way
early yeah to win 75 million bucks to go
take a shot at some of these weird guys
like put put put a grant on Hillary
you'd be surprised because she's the
person that she could somehow creep up
in there and if she gets facing off
against somebody she may end up winning
if you if you're if you're the type of
person that goes to races and bets on
the horse that's one to 99. put it back
on Hillary put a buck on uh uh the rock
put 10 bucks on Michelle because those
are some of the wild cards I'll go I'll
go with you I'm because
I sort of got yeah if we put
collectively us four we put a thousand
on Newsome and that and he wins that's
16 G's I'm the if you're down I'll do it
no because wait wait wait because who's
gonna out of all the of all the
Democrats I can't believe Joe Biden's up
there closer over newsom's over Kamala
Harris what above
um first of all think about the DNC
kamahara says no chance I think you're
onto something yeah and it's it's not
who has no chance it's who will the DNC
allow to get access to the large boom
bucket of Soros money that is controlled
by the DNC yeah and they are not gonna
let Pete go they are not gonna he
doesn't have National electability they
are not gonna Michelle doesn't want to
come a logo and Gavin's the guy that's a
key point because yeah
Joe Biden exactly I was about to say
that don't forget what the DNC did to
Bernie yeah they wrecked him
they didn't want that social
it's good for headlines it's good for
Ratings it's good to sell ads on CNN but
there is a certain reality that's under
this so we have there will be a
presidential election on a combination
of four and only four names Trump
DeSantis Biden and Newsom yep I agree
put the biz doc on a short clip rerun it
once a month I don't think I'm wrong
I'll say one thing and this actually
doesn't even have to do with Trump I
mean it's reference to him but I think I
what you said could not be understated
here okay or overstated about
Reinventing yourself and I'm going to
speak from personal experience and this
is why it's so important to have
somebody you trust and that has been
there before in your ear so Pat told me
for a couple years Adam you got to kind
of reinvent yourself you do the money
stuff save that money save the money
what else can you do what else are you
really really good at and we sat down we
had a strategy session well you're good
at networking you're good at
relationships you're good at partying
you know a lot of people like why don't
you kind of incorporate that into your
brand and what was my first reaction you
didn't want to do it ah Pat let me just
save that money let me just kind of do
my thing and finally before we move into
the new office we had a strategy session
and I had to reinvent myself and it's
very hard to do to reinvent yourself to
do a self-audit to say all right this
was my brand can I switch what can I
improve and this is for everyone out
there yeah this isn't even a trump thing
this is who's talking to you who's in
your ear who do you trust who's your
Mentor who's your friend who's a leader
that can kind of help you through this
process a but B you have to look in the
mirror and see what can you do what can
you do different what can you improve
upon so that's something that I had to
do that's something that you've done
that's something that we've all done my
fear with Trump is you know they say a
leopard cannot change its spots he's
been doing this bit for 76 years it's
gonna be very hard for him to change if
he does if he does I think he can win if
he does the same old thing that you know
lock her up up and build the wall and
you know victim mentality I think I
think it could have a very ugly ending
for sporty or future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
[Music]